my friends I was saddened and shocked at
this deeply offensive video of these
belligerent
misogynists who are yelling at poor AOC
simply because she's funding War and the
azov Battalion and defending the
establishment what did she do wrong
other than all of those things all right
here's the reality AOC got heckled at a
virtually empty Town Hall in the Bronx
protester says she voted to start this
war in Ukraine and will push the US to
the brink of nuclear war Bravo to these
activists two guys calling her out
saying they believed in her and now
she's become a shill for the
establishment providing funding for war
and Nazis in Ukraine I love it and so I
tweeted this out in response to these
activists saying that I pulled up a
story from NBC NBC news saying Putin's
false Nazi claims about Ukraine and then
I pulled up another story from NBC News
the Nazi problem in Ukraine Ukraine is
very real even if Putin is lying about
it so now they're outright just saying
it huh why is AOC the anti-fascist the
leftist
voting to give money to Nazis
why is this why is she voting to fund
War
now Bravo for these guys speaking out
and calling her out but I think this is
the start we need this this is probably
our best our best Avenue in that the
older generation is going to ignore and
probably not care about uniparty voters
Democrats and Republicans who support
War but the younger generation is is
much more disillusioned and angry about
it AOC just knifed them all in the back
by by supporting all this I don't know
why she is because she's a shell she's
always been a shill she's not alone
though I mean they're even when you go
back to previous Wars under Democratic
administrations when you go back to
Kosovo in the 90s when you go back to
Libya under Barack Obama there was at
least a subset there weren't they
weren't the mainstream Democrats but
they were a subset of progress
self-styled Progressive Democrats who
would vote against funding these wars
who would join lawsuits against
presidential Wars there really isn't
anything like that going on right now
every single Democrat in Congress voted
for the 40 billion dollar Aid package to
Ukraine and I don't know if these
activists heckling AOC mean that there
is still some Grassroots anti-war left
out there that is just not represented
by anybody in congress and if they start
speaking up maybe they will be or if
this is sort of the last gasp of that
sentiment it's it's die I mean Tulsi
gabbard was it right what about Bernie
is he's did he vote to send all the
money
Bernie did too huh yeah they're not a
single one didn't Barbara Lee rocana
people who are generally very good on a
lot of who've worked across the aisle on
things like Yemen uh have really been
nowhere to be seen on this one I think
Cortez is she's pretty responsive to the
crowd and this guy this Heckler I I
don't even know I'm not sure if Heckler
is the writer because he wasn't
insulting her he was just screaming in
panic that if she doesn't stop this that
we're gonna die in a nuclear war and
he's like he's the terror in his voice
is palpable it seems like he's not wrong
she's she responds to emotions so yeah
definitely I'm not encouraging people to
go scream at politicians but I mean
they're there to represent us and if
they're not representing us that we need
to make our voices heard Trump Russia is
a big part of this too the the fact that
the whole Trump Russia narrative became
so big on the left that Vladimir Putin
where where is is viewed by some
Grassroots Democrats is the man who
installed the orange man in in power in
the United States so that created a lot
of anti-russia sentiment among people
who maybe even during the Cold War when
it might have been more Justified didn't
have these types of sentiments so I
think there was more openness to
hawkishness against Russia because of
domestic political disputes and domestic
political tribalism that might have
existed otherwise especially among some
people on the center to hard left yeah a
lot of the anti-war representatives got
kicked out or pushed out or forced out
of their of their parties whether it's
kucinich or McKinney these were
individuals that of course were speaking
out against war and their districts were
moved around shoved around in a way
where of course they didn't have a
political career afterwards so you know
there is a deliberate effort to have a
pro-war message to have a message that
supports the military-industrial complex
a major Lobby in Washington DC so I I do
believe that a lot of people who had
significant voices are afraid of being
pushed out of politics for for doing so
I just had a thought is there we say the
military industrial complex are there
multiple I would imagine there are
multiple complexes there's one that the
liberal economic order is utilizing then
there must be another one that the
Chinese and the Russians yeah definitely
that's exactly what they are where's the
racket but then is there someone at the
top of those organizations that are
capitalizing on both of the uh complexes
I don't know
I don't know
I don't think so I think you've got the
Western military industrial complex that
loves War because it guaranteed
contracts extremely expensive extremely
lucrative but I I I don't think that
there is this Grand cabal that controls
the military apparatus of China Russia
and the west and then puts them against
each other it's not like you know uh in
Sherlock Holmes when more we already got
the book and he's trying to orchestrate
World War One or whatever it's because
whoa is money
yeah I think you're right I don't think
there is somebody at the top I think the
bankers are profiting off of it well but
even then there's multiple they're
probably selling weapons across the
board they're playing both sides yeah I
mean look Obama was sending weapons to
the cartels now there's another story
emerging about something similar the gun
manufacturers being accused of sending
weapons to cartels nobody these
manufacturers don't care it's like give
me the money and the weapons are yours
that's it yeah and I don't think you
can't sue the manufacturer if someone
does something horrible with their
weapon at least I don't think you can
well they're trying now yeah but we're
talking about war even yeah it's like if
we're at war with China ain't nobody
from China going to sue the United
States what are you doing we're at War
like actively killing each other
so I I'd like to say that um you know
we're moving away from all this stuff
but I think for a variety of reasons
there are many people very invested in a
nuclear apocalypse occurring
creepy people evil people callous people
Tim they bought their nuclear bunkers
they want to use them okay they want to
make sure that their money was well
invested and they they want to make sure
they're safe houses in New Zealand and
in Chile are going to be used well I
mean look think about it if you have uh
if it's a publicly traded nuclear bunker
company and you have equity in that when
the nuclear war happens that Stock's
going straight through the roof baby
that's money right that's rare now you
won't be able to trade anywhere because
there won't be a stock market Wall
Street apps electricity or food for that
matter but uh everybody will want what
you got if he bought a nuclear bunker
don't you want to use it yeah I think
the answer is no no hold on the most
expensive nuclear bunker you buy is the
one you buy and never use yeah it's that
old saying you know but it's Insurance
think of your bunker as insurance not as
a goal not as a home retirement putting
it on wedding Registries and baby gift
registers for sure you made a good point
about the video games of War man I think
the young there's an older generation
that has their nuclear bunkers these and
they're like I'm ready to go let's let's
find the next iteration of humanity
after this is all done but then there's
these young people that have been
brainwashed to think it's a freaking
video game and it's that's why they do
the video games yeah in America's Army
that was a specific video game that the
United States government used to train
kids to want to become troops yeah like
specifically I'm watching videos from
the Russian side the Ukrainian side from
a lot of the the battles that are taking
place the majority of of killing and
meaning is happening because of drones
the Russians are using Iranian suicide
drones that are just flying directly
into Ukrainian troops the ukrainians are
you using these quadcopters and they're
just putting grenades inside of them and
then having a button that releases them
and they're literally throwing them into
the Russian trenches and there's a whole
bunch of DJI drones there's a video that
I saw of a Ukrainian drone taking out a
Russian DJI drone yeah and when you look
at a lot of the footage it's straight
out of Call of Duty it's straight out of
all the video games where of course you
get a drone and you get the pilot a
missile you get to send grenades off and
and it's exactly like all the video
games that I played as a kid and and you
can see the footage online because I'm
keeping track of this I want to see
what's really going on I want to see
who's winning I want to see who's losing
I really want to get a real perspective
of what's happening there and you have
to see these videos and there's drones
predominantly drones having huge success
in the in these conflicts I had a friend
that worked in the military and he
worked with some people that were
operating drones told me the story where
he the guy was like you got to see this
footage man the Drone operator so he
showed him and it was the the missile or
the bomb was dropping on this guy who
they thought was working on bombs and it
comes up and you go it goes right up to
the guy you see it going right and the
guy looks up and you see his eyes and
then you realize he's taking a crap and
then the bomb hit and then it it goes
off that's it and but he's like I saw
his eyes like I
that's one way to help you poop
yep it probably just went right into the
toilet as soon as he saw that and then
of course exited his body in every
possible Direction when it did yeah they
thought he was like going to get weapons
and he was just out there like
taking a big old dog but it's so easy
when it's a video game to disassociate
yeah we talked about that a while ago
about Vietnam how and they send out
these conscripts they would fire above
the the Vietcong or whatever because
they really didn't want to shoot him and
so they started implementing new uh
that's when I think they made the
targets and the shapes of people and
stuff like that and then now video games
have become a component of this it's
interesting because there's a
distinction
video games don't make people more
violent we've seen all the studies on
this someone who plays a video game
doesn't all of a sudden be like now I
want to be violent but what video games
do is they they condition you so when it
comes to being violent it is easier for
you to pull the trigger so people who
already have those Tendencies when it
comes to war and conflict you're used to
playing these games you you have a
simulated experience it's it's going to
have an effect on you dude have you seen
escape from tarkov the game it's a first
person shooters hyper realistic and you
fight Russians man you hear the rush
they're screaming in Russian it's crazy
that's like most Call of Duties this is
new yeah I was going to say in One Call
of Duty there's a scene where you play a
child as your city in in Syria is
literally getting gassed and you're
playing as the child running away from
the Russian gas as they said chemical
weapons Call of Duty and yeah one of the
Call of Duty modern warfare games so
you're literally a child running away
from a Russian soldier that that wants
to stab you as there's a chemical uh you
know weapons attack I love how like
America's adversaries are always comic
book villains you know it's like when
you watch the media they you know
Vladimir Putin the evil dictator
murdered children today and it's like
come on man they're adults who
understand why War happens and they want
you to believe that every world leader
is wearing a cloak and a top hat with a
mustache going I'm going to tie a woman
to the railroad tracks no he's probably
saying hey you're pushing your military
Alliance up upon my border and it's and
it's it's it's jeopardizing my country's
interests and I'm not going to let that
happen and he's probably like yo let me
ship steel down to Crimea so I can sail
it over to the United States and sell it
to you like it's I it's so weird it's so
like almost disbelievable that we're
creating an enemy out of the Russian
Federation when it could be our greatest
trade Ally and strongest partner
military partner on Earth it's on the
other side of the planet we could
together protect the planet thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive Library Prairie to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there